NTEMGEPROCEDURE.
IN MPING
E  DOWN OR
WAITIS
IN COLORADO, ONE S
HAENTHE
D IS ISTE 5
ONORG THE CITING RELUS
EM AND UE
E GOVERNOR COLORADDE
PUBLIC TTEHI
IMPACT AN INDIVIDUAL IDAT UALTHW
ROUNWAY.
SAYSITAN H
FEEL LIKE I'M BEIND
IT AND SEET
I HAVE TO  THE S
GUA,.OININN'SANJAY
AN "WORLD
WAR I WAS READIN
INTD.
TH
WITH E E?ISRAHOW DO YOU?
L, DON'T THINK OPLE SHOIT AA PU.
THERE IRE GETS ANT.
TH IMMUNOSUPPRESSIVE DRUGS
WORSE CAUSING DEATH AT SOME
POINTS.
N.
PROHIBITAND THE LINE I
SAYING THESINACCEPTABLE EVEN I
IYOVE NATURAL
IMMUNITY, YOU'VE HAD IN
THE PAST, YOU HAVE PROBABLPRETT
FOR A PERIOD OF TIMET
KNOW HOW LONG THAT PROTECT KNOW
AGE , DEE F OE PROTECT
TYE CCINE THAT IS KNOWN TO BE
AND CTIVE.N SHOTS HA B
OUT AROUND THE WORD ,
ULTIMATELY, THERTY TRANSPLANT MY
ERBE
MA
IT'S THORNY, FOR
AT'SAJ
NS LAN
E IF IU QUBE RD
EXPLAINING THOUSAND ATT SE TO RL
TO EFFICIENCY.
NVLAB.
HORT VERONTHE IGIN, AS OF WHAT
Y ISY LEBET,D
OVER FROM ANIMALS TO
WHY?
PAST.ALLY OCCURRING, WHY?CAUSE G
THAT'S JTH, PLAY
THE ODDSART , THE IS A
LEAT TH
MAN
ONOULD BDISPENINESE GOVERNMENT T
DAT WENT
IT BACK UPWAS THERAN OF THIS
PAUL
THE PROBLEM IS,
AUN
ARISD THAT
SUSPICION, FRANKLY,
UN.20,
,
THE T OF
S WELL
K NT THEHINESE
VEO SCING.ISS WELL TOOK TIME BE
THAT'S THETHE' OF TH